so an auction is a method of price
discovery a method of figuring out what
someone's gonna pay for an item and
who's gonna get it so if I've got a
coca-cola to sell and I've got six
people who want it who's gonna get that
coca-cola and how much are they gonna
pay and any sort of mechanism in which
the potential buyers express desire in
some way and then that turns into both a
price and a determination of who gets it
we call that an auction the Latin root
of auction came from to increase and
your kind of standard auction says we're
gonna let competition push the price up
and until one person is left standing so
probably the most important factor is
price discovery I don't know what this
item is worth you have paintings for
sale and no one really knows you know
what the value of those paintings is
pretty much determined by what people
are willing to pay for them it would be
a really a frustrating thing if when I
went to buy shampoo in the grocery store
I had to go bid on it and wait and well
let other people bid all the while
waiting for my shampoo and so we
typically wouldn't run auctions when we
have enough of the supply that we're
pretty sure we can sell to everybody and
we have a good enough sense of the price
of the value that there's no need to run
through a price discovery method how
come we know the price of shampoo but we
don't know the price of the Mona Lisa in
essence this they can make more shampoo
at roughly the same cost so that we can
have as much shampoo as we need if we
need 10% more shampoo that's not a
problem for the shampoo manufacturer so
as a result while there could be a
shortage and you see this often if
there's a storm coming people come in
they buy all the stuff off the shelves
that would be a time where whether
there's gonna be people who go without
as a result you might think about
holding an auction now let me say most
states have laws that prevent sellers
from holding an auction in that
circumstance though they're not allowed
to take advantage of people who are in
some sense desperate you know otherwise
you know you can go if you need ten
bottles of shampoo you go buy 10 bottles
of shampoo the grocery store doesn't run
out probably the most popular auction is
called an oral ascending auction you see
it in movies where somebody
tugs their ear and they buy a Ming Vaz
by accident the item is put on for sale
there's a minimum bid perhaps or a low
bid that the auctioneer starts with and
then they start with this chatter going
do I have $10 we have $20 I got $20 do I
have $30 or $30 and so on and they the
price rises until at some point there's
only one bidder who's willing to bid at
that price and that is no one is willing
to go up any more sometimes called the
English auction which is common in
England but it's actually common around
the world as a method of auctioning I
believe it was used as far back in time
as the Babylonians this auction has been
around a really long time sealed bid
auction in this case bidders say here is
my head they write it on an envelope
those envelopes are all open
simultaneously the high bidder wins and
they pay their bid sometimes that's
called a pay as bid auction sometimes
usually with a word seal bid and
sometimes it's called a first price
meaning the high bidder paid the high
bid typically it's governments that use
sealed bids much more common to be
government sometimes large corporations
will also use sealed bid the beauty of a
sealed bid relative to an English
auction is that it's hard for the
auctioneer themselves to cheat so our
big concern with the government holding
an auction is that the government
officials might collude with one of the
bidders if the government official did
that there would be a paper trail that
allows it to be audited when I was at
the Department of Justice a bitter
submitted a bid that contained copies of
all their rivals bids in the same
envelope and so we were able to show
really easily that the bidders
themselves were colluding with each
other
price-fixing it's against the law the
bidder had inadvertently submitted a
copy of the rivals bids which they
shouldn't have been able to see
Dutch auction sometimes called a tulip
auction is well known for being used in
the Dutch tulip auctions it's an oral
auction that is it's used with an
auctioneer and all the bidders assembled
together and it starts high and then
runs low if we're selling tulips we'll
say is anybody willing to pay $10,000
we're we're pretty sure that no one's
willing to pay $10,000 the price is
successively lowered until someone says
I'll take it and at that moment it sells
to that bidder at the price that they
bid from a theoretical standpoint this
auction is actually identical to the
sealed bid auction and if you think
about it when you submit a bid in a
sealed bid auction you're thinking well
the other bidders will bid whatever they
bid and I win if I'm the highest now
imagine yourself in the position of
bidding in the Dutch auction you're
saying I have to choose a bid and when
the price reaches that bid that's the
moment I'm going to jump in I'm thinking
will the other one's bid higher than
that in which case I'll lose but if I
put in a higher bid I might win but I
pay more it's exactly the same thought
process that you face with the sealed
bid auction so in fact theoretically the
same bidder should win at the same price
whether I hold a Dutch or a sealed bid
when we actually run experiments it's
not true people jump a little bit
earlier in the Dutch auction that is
they bid a little bit higher maybe
because of the excitement of it just the
time while they wait is making them
nervous or something they're less
rational we don't know but they bid a
little bit higher in the Dutch auction
than they do in the seal bid
the second price sealed bid auction or
also known as the Vickrey auction after
William Vickery who won the Nobel Prize
for its discovery along with some other
things about auctions he did this work
in 1961
so the way Vickery's auction works is it
works just like the seal bid that we
described before but now when we open
the envelopes the high bidder will win
but they pay the second highest bid not
the highest bid it's the minimum they
could have been and still won there's
one way to think about it this is the
price of that had they known what all
the other bids were this is what they
would have wanted to bid is that maybe
plus a penny to guarantee they're wet if
I am paying the second highest price
I'll will I'll be willing to bid a lot
more aggressively
if you've bid an ebay this is how eBay
works you submit a bid let's say for
$100 when another bid comes in at 40
they then turn around and give it to you
at 40 plus the increment which might be
45 if that bidder comes back with 60
they'll then give it again to you for 60
plus the increment there around 65 that
process continues unless someone
actually bids higher than you so what
that's implemented is a second price
auction that is to say you don't pay
your bid you could have been a million
dollars you still pay the next highest
bid plus a little bit and the smaller
that little bit is the more it looks
exactly like the victory which is paying
the second highest price
it's easy to cheat a second-price
auction because you actually see what
people are willing to pay so you could
just go to the high bidder and say oh
the second highest bid was just a penny
below your bid you're gonna have to pay
approximately your bid
well they've revealed it and that can be
dangerous that's the downside of it the
upside of it is that it actually gets
this competitive pressure of that oral
auction which has you know it's a great
auction for getting for extracting lots
of money out of people but without
requiring them to be in the same room or
even to be humans and a good example of
that the big search auctions won by
Google and Bing
they are second price auctions you bid
but what you pay is just what it would
take to hold your slot then let me let's
let's just think about the first price
sealed bid or the pay as bid and the
Vickrey auction when I'm thinking about
what I should bid - a first price sealed
bid I say well I'm gonna pay my bid so
let's say my value is a hundred and I
think about submitting a bid of $75 that
means if I win I get $25 if I lower my
bid a bit well there's some chance I get
beat but I make more money when I do win
the seal bid auction causes me to cut my
bid a lot because that's where my profit
is on the Vickrey auction in contrast
then I'm gonna bid $100 because I want
to win anytime the price comes out below
$100 so that comes in level that's just
gravy it's all extra money for me it's
all money in my pocket so there's no
price advantage of lowering your bid
there's only a did I win
well I only want to win whenever the
price is below my value now that's
assuming I know my value somebody came
along when I was a graduate student and
offered to sell me a fairly new car for
$50 you know something's wrong with this
like it's stolen it's too cheap in some
sense it's too cheap well I didn't buy
it by the way let's tweak the scenario a
little bit now they come in they offer
you sell you a car for $2000 that really
should sell for more like four or five
thousand dollars you're kind of nervous
there's something that you don't know
about this car is it really worth $2,000
and maybe you need a car and you would
like to buy it but you're still very
suspicious - this car is worthwhile if
it turns out though that ten other
people who
cars pretty well had bid 1,600 1,800
1,900 dollars there could be a lot more
willing to pay $2,000 so the effect of
this is if I know another bidder is
willing to pay more for it rationally I
will actually increase my value or I
will be less skeptical that it's
actually a pig in a poke what that means
is the English auction this oral
ascending auction does a good job
inducing people to bid more why because
when the price goes up I say oh well
there's another bidder at least one
other bidder willing to pay this I then
say okay good I'm comfortable with that
and I beat them that causes them to say
oh yes well there's another bidder
willing to pay it and they go on the
more of that kind of information that's
released the more price pressure there
is and the more will push prices up that
auction does a good job extracting money
out of people because of the release of
information about value from the other
bidders The effect of this is is that in
a Vickrey auction we get some of those
benefits not all of them you know in a
ascending auction I might see that there
were ten other bidders in the Vickrey
auction all I'm really guaranteed is at
least one other bidder was willing to
pay what I'm gonna be asked to pay for
the item that tends to drive up values
and hence tends to drive up prices on
average and that's good for the seller
it's also good for the buyer in the
following sense they wind up getting
lower profits but they also lower the
possibility or the likelihood that they
lose money so we've only talked about
one good item says we're only selling
one item you know almost all the
circumstances I deal with we're selling
lots of items so there turns out to be a
version of the victory for that world
it's got some defects in New Zealand was
an early adopter of the Vickrey auction
they sold telecom licenses and the
National Cellular license the high bid
was a hundred and ten million dollars in
the second highest bid that is the price
in the Vickrey auction was 11 million
this is like headline news government
sells a hundred and ten million dollar
license for 11 million dollars sometimes
it's actually a bad idea to find out
what the value is or at least to make it
public
had they run that as an ascending
auction this wouldn't have half
but they still would have missed out on
a bunch of money they could have had
from the person willing to pay a hundred
and ten million no it just wouldn't have
been known not necessarily let's take
the case where they ran a sealed bid
auction first price pay your bid the
bidder who was willing to pay a hundred
and ten million certainly wouldn't have
been a hundred and ten million that
would have left them with no profit
instead they'd have said who's the
likely competition here how much in the
way of resources does that competitor
had and they'd have come up with a
number and maybe that number would have
been 12 million in which case that had
gotten an extra million but maybe that
number would have been ten million in
which case they'd have lost a million
it's not exactly clear what's true is
you wouldn't expect it to be a lot more
and in fact the mathematics of it
suggests you would you would expect less
on average from using that sealed bid
auction than from using the Vickrey
auction but you wouldn't have kept it
secret and so you shouldn't think of it
as being yes I have gotten all that
money had I run a seal bid auction no
not at all in fact you might have even
gotten less what's your advice to
someone who wants to succeed on a bag
most things that sell on eBay there's
more than one copy of it so that is to
say you there are multiple copies of it
and so the hard problem on eBay
is not so much what to bid on the item
but which auction to bid in so my first
advice is if you want something and
you're not in a hurry if you're in a
hurry I'll buy it now if you want
something and you're not in a hurry
watch what the outcomes are because eBay
doesn't really make this all that easy
to know what what things sell for track
how much it sells for in different
auctions and that gives you a well if
I'm willing to wait six weeks here's
what I expect to pay if I'm willing to
wait three months I will expect to pay
less I'll see an auction that shows up
with a lower price and so that gives you
information that arms you about what to
bid and then secure our submitted in one
auction as soon as it gets be Co
submitted in another auction as soon as
that gets beat go submit it in a third
auction and so on when you do this you
should favor auctions that are about to
expire why because that way you get the
information earlier about whether you're
going to get beat so you're kind of
running what we call a search algorithm
trying to find which auction is going to
get the item to sell at that low price
this obviously only applies for items
that are where there's more than one
item but that is the bulk of the things
that sell on eBay
that building behind me that's the
mathematical sciences Research Institute
and that's where today's video was made
if you'd like to find out more about
them the mathematics that's done here
and also the math outreach they support
you can find out more by some links I've
put in the description under the video